hyman wohlgemerkt mit c am anfang an
sprechen sehen hören verstehen und
fliegen und seit wenigen tagen ist er
der neue mitbewohner und sauber kollege
von alexander gerst auf der raumstation
iss samen ist ein autonom agierender
astronauten assistent und mit
künstlicher intelligenz ausgestattet und
soll an bord demonstrieren wie eine
zusammenarbeit von menschen und
intelligenten maschinen zukünftig
gestaltet werden könnte was hat sein und
auf dem kasten
wie genau kann er gast und kolleginnen
und kollegen unter die arme greifen will
ist dass die raumfahrt der zukunft jetzt
wirklich zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
[Musik]
der private raumfrachter dragon von
ihnen us firma spacex war ende juni
richtung iss gestartet mit im gepäck
waren nicht nur verpflegung und
technische geräte sondern auch der neue
cyber kollege für alexander gerst und
kolleginnen und kollegen der roboter
seinen zeilen steht für crew interactive
mobile companion und wird somit zum 17
kopf der besatzung dabei ist er nur etwa
so groß wie ein medizinball genauso rund
wiegt auf der erde 5 kilogramm und hat
einen durchmesser von 32 cm
diamond ist damit weltweit der erste
fliegende und autonom agierende
astronauten assistent ausgestattet mit
künstlicher intelligenz sein vorbild
stammt aus der zeichentrickserie captain
future nämlich das fliegende gehirn
ausgestattet mit einem sprachprozessor
kameras und sensoren und dem namen
professor steven wright doch diese
science fiction ist jetzt tatsächlich
realität entwickelt und gebaut wurde der
roboter in deutschland und zwar vom
deutschen zentrum für luft- und
raumfahrt dlr
dazu der projektleiter christian karas
heimen ist in dieser form weltweit
einzigartig dieses experiment soll
zeigen wie weit es möglich ist die
astronauten im europäischen columbus
modul der einst es bei ihren arbeiten zu
unterstützen und sie vor allem bei
routineaufgaben zu entlasten im
idealfall könnten die astronauten
dadurch ihre zeit noch besser und
effektiver nutzen wir betreten hier
neuland und bewegen uns mit seilen an
der schwelle des technologisch machbar
dabei muss man wissen dass die technik
an bord der iss ziemlich veraltet ist
sie wurde vor jahrzehnten entwickelt und
ansonsten sind da einige laptops die
struktur des neuen server kollegen wurde
in einem 3d verfahren gedruckt sie
besteht aus kunststoff und metall ein
display stellt sein gesicht da und
dieses soll sich immer auf augenhöhe der
astronautinnen und astronauten bewegen
und zwar schweben zwei kameras dienen
als siemens augen eine weitere kamera
kümmert sich um die funktion der
gesichtserkennung und zwei weitere
kameras sind für die videodokumentation
und zusatzfunktionen wie augmented
reality eingebaut
seine ohren bestehen aus acht mikrofonen
und ermöglichen zusammen eine richtungs
und spracherkennung und nicht andauernd
gegen andere dinge oder menschen zu
stoßen gibt es außerdem eine kollision
erkennung die mit ultraschallsensoren
funktioniert über seinen lautsprecher
mund kann er sprechen oder musik spielen
trainiert werden kann er nur durch
menschen selbstständiges lernen steht
dagegen nicht auf seiner agenda
insgesamt 14 interne propeller machen
ihn beweglich in alle möglichen
raumrichtungen wenn er angesprochen wird
wendet er sich seinen gesprächspartner
zu nickt und schüttelt mit dem kopf und
folgt auf kommandos in der
schwerelosigkeit an bord der iss kann er
bis zu zwei stunden im einsatz sein doch
wie genau kann er der iss-crew bei ihrer
arbeit helfen
er dient als komplexe datenbank für alle
arbeiten auf der ss und kann zudem als
mobile kamera eingesetzt werden durch
siemens anwesenheit haben die
astronauten bei ihrer arbeit beide hände
frei denn sie müssen dann die computer
nicht mehr manuell bedienen mit der
tastatur irgendwas suchen sondern
stattdessen können sie sprachgesteuert
zugriff auf alle dokumente und medien
bekommen und außerdem auch die
anweisungen für bedienungs und reparatur
prozesse an bord alexander gerst soll
insgesamt drei mal mit seinem neuen
cyber kollegen zusammenarbeiten unter
anderem steht ein medizinisches
experiment auf der agenda
bei der der roboter als fliegende kamera
genutzt hat das projekt soll zeigen wie
künstliche intelligenz menschen in solch
einem komplizierten umfeld wie immer an
bord der internationalen raumstation der
ss unterstützen kann langfristig gesehen
so als sei man nach dem plan seines
entwicklungsteams noch weitere talente
hinzubekommen dazu der projektleiter
till eisenberg mittelfristig wollen wir
uns auch gruppen effekten widmen die
sich bei kleinen teams über lange zeit
hinweg entwickelt und bei langzeit
missionen zum mond und mars auftreten
können denn die soziale interaktion
zwischen mensch und maschine zwischen
astronaut und mit emotionaler
intelligenz ausgestatteten flugbegleiter
könnte eine wichtige rolle für den
erfolg dieser missionen spiel auch in
sachen big data also riesiger
datenmengen und ihrer verarbeitung data
mining soll weiter geforscht werden
langfristig sollen solche cyber kollegen
die crew an bord auch medizinisch
gesehen entlasten denn die
schwerelosigkeit fordert tribut vom
menschlichen körper
der kollege sei man könnte vor allem in
sachen stress und zeitdruck eine große
hilfe sein scheinen könnte also zu einem
zentralen bestandteil zukünftiger
raumfahrt missionen werden wie zum
beispiel zum mars ja wenn ihr keine
videos dazu und zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei
whatsapp dann und geht in die kaputte
abo boxee auf youtube und verpasst kein
video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich und garantiert einfach
hier draufklicken und am besten auch
meinen schwesterkanal klicks zum social
media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste
aus der social media welt dafür hier
klicken aber nicht die genauen vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit darf auch
draufklicken 1000 raketen zum master
könnte dann vielleicht heimen auch
eingesetzt werden bis dann bleibt dran